حياكم الله اذا اجواء ايجابيه شهدتها
الساعات الاخيره في يوميات ازمه شرقي
المتوسط هاه تركيا واليونان توافقان على
استئناف محادثات استكشافيه كما سميت بين
الجانبين قريبا في اسطنبول المحادثات
متوقفه منذ
2016 الرئيس التركي يقترح عقد مؤتمر
اقليمي لبحث سبل انهاء النزاع وانباء عن
تقدم في المحادثات التقنيه بين العسكريين
الاتراك
واليونانيين المنعقد تحت مظله النيتو من
انقره جاءت اشاره لافته في بيان للسفاره
الامريكيه يقول ان الولايات المتحده لا
تعترف باي اهميه قانونيه لما اصطلح على
تسميتها بخارطه اشبيليا التي اعدتها
اليونان بخصوص الحدود البحريه بينها وبين
تركيا اي رساله تبعث بها واشنطن اليوم ما
اهميه المؤشرات الاخيره في صراع المتوسط
تابع تقرير ناصر
اطار لا تستعجل جيح سيناريو على اخر ففي
خلافات الدول هناك للحوار دوما فرصه ربما
استوعبت ذلك اثنا وانقره كلتاهما تبدي
رغبه في استئناف مفاوضات استكشافيه ثنائيه
بشان المناطق البحريه وتسارع وسائل اعلام
يونانيه الى القول ان المفاوضات
وشيكه عام 2016 انهارت كما نذكر نقاشات
مماثله طويله بين بين اليونانيين والاتراك
حول ترسيم الحدود
البحريه فهل تفلح المفاوضات المباشره
الاحدث اذا تمت في جسر هوه الخلاف حول
نطاق السياده في البحر المتوسط وحقوق
التنقيب عن الطاقه هناك وهل يهدئ التوترات
مؤتمر اقليمي دعا اليه الرئيس التركي لبحث
سبل انهاء ذلك
النزاع جعل الرئيس اردوغان من الاجتماع ال
للجمعيه عامه للامم المتحده منصه لاطلاق
دعوته كلمته عبر الدائره الالكترونيه
المغلقه حثت ايضا على ما دعاه حوارا صادقا
بشان شرق المتوسط ثمت من يتفاءل خيرا بهذا
التطور وباخر برز في
بروكسل المباحثات الفنيه التي يرعاها حلف
شمال الاطلسي بين الدولتين اللتين تشتركان
في عضويته احرزت تقدما وصف بالجيد والبناء
هي مباحثات هدفها وضع اليه لفض النزاع
وتجنب الحوادث
العسكريه غير ان الامين العام للحلف يحرص
على اعتبارها استكمالا للعمل الدبلوماسي
الجاري لعله يقصد ذاك الذي تطلع به
المانيا مع مستشارته انجيلا ميركل ومع
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارل ميشيل بحث
الرئيس التركي عبر تقنيه الاتصال المرئي
ازمه المتوسط العلاقه مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتواصل الرئيس اردوغان هاتفيا في
هذا الشان حتى مع نظيره الفرنسي الذي
طالما انتقد انحيازه لليونان ليس ذاك موقف
كل دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي قبل يومين من قمه ذات صله بالملف
يلاحظ الاتحاد بان المشهد المتوسطي حاليا
اكثر ايجابيه مما كان عليه قبل شهر وربما
كانت الاجواء الجانحه في مجملها الى
التهدئه هي ما شجع الامريكيين على الدخول
على خط الازمه بقدر اكبر من الفاعليه
وربما الاتزان حثوا الجانبين التركي
واليوناني على استئناف اتصالاتهما
الاستكشافيه في اقرب وقت ممكن وقالت
سفارتهم في انقره ان الولايات المتحده مع
حل توافقي لمساله الحدود البحريه قائم على
اساس القانون الدولي اما اكثر مواقف
واشنطن مدعاه للتامل فرفضها الصريح
الاعتراف باي اهميه قانونيه لما اصطلح على
تسميتها بخريطه
اشبيه عام 2000 وضع خوان لويس سارث دي
بيبيرو استاذ الجغرافيا البحريه والبشريه
الاسباني خريطه لحدود الاتحاد الاوروبي
البحريه واستند الرجل في ذلك الى وجهه نظر
اليونان وقبرص اليونانيه الخريطه التي لا
يعتبرها الاتحاد الاوروبي نفسه وثيقه
ملزمه قانونيا تجعل اليونان تبتلع بحري
ايجا والمتوسط وموارده ما كما تحاصر تركيا
في شريط ساحلي ضيق للغايه لذلك تحاول اثنا
فرض ما تسمى خريطه اشبيليا اساسا
للتفاوض ولذلك ترفضها انقره بشكل
مطلق يقول فؤاد اقطاعي نائب الرئيس التركي
انه لو رسم الخريطه ذئب بحق حمل لما كان
مجحفا بهذا
القدر لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
اسطنبول عبر الانترنت رسول توسون
البرلماني السابق عن حزب العداله والتنميه
من اثناء معنا البروفيسور بنايوس تساكوس
من الاستاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
اثينا من ماريلاند عبر الانترنت
البروفيسور تشارلز كبشن رئيس وكبير
الباحثين للدراسات الاوروبيه في مجلس
العلاقات الخارجيه والمختص بشؤون النيتو
اهلا بكم جميعا ابدا معك رسول طوسون عندما
تعلن الرئاسه التركيه ان تركيا واليونان
ستبدين محادثات استكشافيه في
اسطنبول هل نحن بصدد يعني نقطه تحول في
طريق
الحل نتمنى ذلك كما تعرفين تركيا من
البدايه تعلن انها مستعده الحوار ولجل على
طاوله الحوار لحل القضيه او لحل المشكله
بالطرق السلميه لكن كلما خطت تركيا هذه
الخطوات السلميه عندما سحبت السفينه
اي برجاء السيده ماركن راينا ان اليونان
راحت
ووقعت اتفاقيه ترسيم الحدود مع مصر
استغلالا لهذه الفرصه فايضا عندما سحبت
تركيا سفينتها قبل ايام
للصيانه ايضا فتحت مجال ل
مجال فتحت مجالا
للدبلوماسي لكن في كل هذه التطورات او كل
هذه
التصرفات صصح يعني ذات المرونه راينا
الطرف
اليوناني المدلل من قب الاتحاد الاوروبي
اي يعني
اي تهربت من الجلوس الى
طاوله لكن بعد ان بعد ان رات بعد ان رات
الموقف الاوروبي الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك
الموقف الامريكي يبدو ان الطرف اليوناني
سيجلس على طائله الحوار لكن انا شخصيا لا
يعني اي
ارى نتيجه ايجابيه بعد
هذه المحادثات المحت ساعود اليك في هذه
النقطه اريد ان اسال ضيفي من اثينا تساكوس
الان يعني اثنا تبدي مرونه بعد ان مرت
مرحله من التصعيد الكلامي وغيره ما الجديد
في من وجهه نظر اليونان لكي تقول انها
مستعده لكي تذهب الى اسطنبول وتبدا
محادثات استكشافيه من
جديد اعتقد ان اليونان كانت دائما
مستعده للدخول في حوار وهناك عده امثله في
الماضي حيث كانت اليونان هي التي اعربت عن
استعدادها لدخول في مفاوضات مع تركيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي وفي 2002 على وجه
الخصوص كنا مستعدين للدخول في مفاوضات
استكشافيه لكن قرارا
تركيا في مارس
2016 اعاق ذلك ولكن ما هو مهم ان نلاحظه
وهو انه وبعد فتره من التوتر والتصعيد في
الشرق المتوسط بات في مصلحه الطرفين ان
ينخرط في حوار صادق فيما يسمى بمحادثات
مفاوضات استكشافيه ليرى كلا الطرفين كيف
يمكن ان يستمع الى مخاوف ومواقف وبواعث
قلق الطرف الاخر بحيث يفضي ذلك الى حوار
يؤدي الى وضع جدول اعمال يمكن ي من خلاله
تحقيق تقدم طيب استمعت الى ما قاله رسول
توسون سيد تساكوس قبل قليل قال انه غير
متفائل تماما لا يعتقد انها ستؤدي الى شيء
وانا اريد ان اسالك شيء يعني الحديث عن
حسن النيه الان قبل تقريبا ساعتين من الان
وزير الخارجيه
اليوناني غرد بان صحيح ان
هناك استئناف للمفاوضات ولكنه يقول انه
يجب على الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض عقوبات على
تركيا في حال لم يتم التوصل الى حل لماذا
استعمال هذه المصطلحات في هذا الوقت في
الوقت اللي نتحدث عن حل
حله انا على قناعه من ان اليونان وما قامت
به حتى الان هو ابراز حقيقه ان العلاقات
بين بلدان المنطقه يجب ان تستند وترتكز
الى القانون الدولي وما ينبغي ان نتذكره
هو ان
اليونان تمضي خطوات الى الامام متخذه كل
الاجراءات اللازمه التي يدعمها القانون
الدولي
العقوبات لن تؤدي غرضها باي شكل من
الاشكال و
كما يرى ويعتقد بعض الناس في اليونان او
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وانا لا افضل
العقوبات شخصيا وما افضله هو مقاربه تكون
اوسع نطاقا تستند الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتقدم من قبله
تتضمن سياسه العصا والجزره عقوبات
ومغريات ايضا فهذا من شانه ان يق قدم حزمه
ملموسه من القضايا المهمه التي تهم تهم
تركيا كثيرا وعدى عن بحث مساله العقوبات
اتقد ان من الافضل والمثمر اكثر ان ينصب
الحديث على علاقات جديده بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي
وتركيا ترتكز الى القضايا
الاساسيه والتي تهم تركيا واليونان
والاتحاد الاوروبي وهي الاقتصاد والتجاره
وربما قد يتخذ تتخذ هذه العلاقه
شكل تنظيم علاقه او اتفاق جمركي بين
الاطراف وثم قضيه الهجره التي هي مهمه
للاتحاد استك هنا اريد ان اذهب لتشارلز
كبشن
واسالك يعني الحديث عن الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكنه ليس الطرف الوحيد المعني بما يجري
على ما يبدو فواشنطن
الان تقول يعني كان لافتا التصريح ل من
قبل السفاره الامريكيه في انقره وال من
خلال التويتر والذي تقول فيه ان يجب على
تركيا واليونان استئناف المحادثات في اسرع
وقت ممكن
ا هل هذا يعني ان واشنطن الان تصعد
من تدخلها في محاولاتها ل حل الازمه ام
ماذا ما الذي نفهمه من هذا
الكلام اعتقد ان
واشنطن قد زادت في اهتمامها
ومخاوفها حيال هذه الازمه لانك دائما اذا
ما رايت خصومه بين عضوين من اعضاء حلف
النيتو يتصارعان فهذا مبعث قلق وطبعا
القضيه تتعلق بالتنقيب عن الجاز وارساء
الحدود البحريه وله ايضا علاقه مع السياق
العام في الموضوع وهي المتمثله
بتدخل روسيا في شرق
المتوسط مع تركيا ايضا في سياق العلاقه
التركيه الفرنسيه في ليبيا الولايات
المتحده بشكل عام حاولت النايه بنفسه عن
هذه الازمات لكن نرى انها بادت
باتت حريصه اكثر و على التدخل وتريد
لمفاوضات ان تبدا ولحسن الحظ المفاوضات
مجدوله لتبدا في اسطنبول وايضا للدخول في
قضايا تحكيم متبادله بين الطرفين ولا
اعتقد اننا يجب من الان ان نشير باص باصبع
الاتهام الى اي طرف ولا نقول الخطا خطا
اليونان او خطا تركيا بل نرمي الى تخفيف
حده التوتر واضح ان السفاره الامريكيه
ايضا يعني عندما علقت
على خارطه اشبيليا وقالت انها ليس لها اي
اهميه قانونيه والسؤال موجه لرسول
توسون يعني البعض اعتبر ان هذا يعني تضخيم
للامور مبالغه في الاهتمام بهذه الجزئيه
على اعتبار ان الاعلام التركي كان يتحدث
عنه بشده وا يعني السفاره رات ان تعلق على
هذا الامر هل فعلا هو الامر كذلك ام هناك
فعلا تغيير حقيقي في الموقف الامريكي
والسياسه الامريكيه تجاه
الازمه السياسه الا الامريكيه للاسف
الشديد سياسه يعني العصى والجسر ف عندما
تعلن السفاره الامريكيه في انقره ان خارطه
اشبيليه لا اهميه لها لكن من جانب اخر نرى
نفس الدوله اي الولايات المتحده اي تقوم
بمناورات
عسكريه في ال حدود التركيه مع اليونان
خلافا
للاتفاقيات الدوليه خاصه اتفاقيه لوزان
اختي الكريمه نحن نرى ان اليونان وان كانت
تركيا جاهزه مستعده للجلوس على الحوار
ولحل السياسي لكن جارتنا اليونان لا تريد
حلا سياسيا اعتمادا على بعض الدول
الاتحاديه كما تفضلت قبل قليل قبل ساعتين
عندما يستعد الطرفان للجلوس على الطاوله
تهدد اليونان الطرف التركي ولكن ايضا هناك
تطور اوروبي يعني اريد ان اذهب الى بانيوس
تساكوس
عندما يتصل ماكرون
ب الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ويتحدث عن
الازمه بطريقه ربما يعتبر هذا شيء جديد
هذا حصل قبل ساعتين ايضا من الان هل اصبح
التصعيد خلف ظهرنا ام ان نحن في مرحله
يعني نستشف منها ان هناك هدوء يسبق
العاصفه وهل الكره في ملعب اثينا
تماما
السؤال موجه لي للسيد باتس تساكوس
باختصار شديد لو سمحت لم يبقل كثير اعتقد
ان الكره في ملعب الطرفين
كليهما وعلى كلا الطرفين ان يبدا في
الدخول في حوار مخلص قد يتخذ شكل حوار في
البدايه ثم
يتحول الى حادثات استكشافيه ايا كان يجب
ان تكون سمتها الاخلاص والاستناد الى
القانون الدولي وعلي ان اشدد على هذه
النقطه لان لهذه النقطه اهميه قصوى لاننا
وخاصه في
مستهل المحادثات الاستكشافيه يجب ان نبرز
ما تم تعها جميعا عن كثب اشكرك سيد
بوناس مننا شكرا لرسول توسون من من انقره
وشكرا
لتشارلز كوبشن من ماريلاند وشكرا لكم ايضا
مشاهدينا في
م